hi and welcome to my video series of
piyo techniques explained in five
minutes where I explain a concept of
biology in less than five minutes if you
haven't yet subscribe to my channel hit
that subscribe button and please leave
your comments after this video your
comments give me motivation to make more
such videos now today's installment will
talk about the east
artificial chromosome or yak so let us
talk about the features of yak yak has
centromeric sequence which is essential
for it to propagate inside the East
it has East origin of replication and
also origin of replication in bacteria
you must be wondering why it has oreo of
bacteria because most of the cases the
yak is designed in such a manner that it
could work like a shuttle vector you can
shuttle between East and bacterial so
that's why it has bacterial art but
bacterial origin of replication as well
now it has telomeric sequence because
telomere is important for stability of
any chromosome inside a eukaryote right
and selectable marker and selectable
marker for both the species for bacteria
and for the east now at the end it has
multiple cloning site which is the
common feature because any cloning
vector should have multiple cloning site
and then strategically to BAM h1 sites
are placed flanking the telomeres and
we'll learn about why they're specially
designed to keep their and so East
artificial chromosome is a cloning
vector and especially it is used to
clone Pig DNA fragments as big as like
several mega base pairs so in circular
format East can be grown inside a
bacteria now they could be isolated just
like a plasmid and then we digest it
using the BAM h1 remember the BAM h1
sites were flanking the telomere so if
you restrict with bam each one then the
fragment a certain fragment would fall
off and that is washed away that's a
stuffer fragment and the circular vector
is now linearized and this linear
linearized vector is now can be
restricted with another enzyme which is
present in its multiple cloning site
let's say eco r1 and after restriction
digestion in the multiple cloning site
we can insert our gene of interest or
the DNA fragment of interest which could
range from several KB's to several mb/s
and that's the biggest advantage of
using artificial chromosome because it
has a huge carrying capacity and yet it
is quite stable now after inserting the
gene of interest now we have to insert
this whole East artificial chromosome
vector inside
East and that is done by transformation
reaction in case of East the preferred
transformation mode is via
electroporation because East has cell
wall and it is very hard to get the DNA
in with just hit chop method so
transformation via electroporation is
the preferred method then it is grown in
form of colonies and next day when you
see the colonies you would find the
recombinant colonies should be red in
color because East is East artificial
chromosome must initially design in such
a way that it has a suppressor for gene
as a screw noble marker in its multiple
cloning site
now once you and once you clone your
gene of interest earned in a fragment of
interest in this multiple cloning site
it would disrupt the software gene now
this sub suppressor for cannot anymore
suppress the red colour of the East
colonies and that's why the recombinant
colonies are all red so any red colonies
you see they are recombinant now East
artificial chromosomes are specially
used to make genomic DNA libraries
especially for those genomes which are
really big like human genome or like
mammalian genome etc and yeast
artificial chromosomes could be used for
making transgenic mouse models
especially cloning those genes which are
very big now instead of having all these
kind of advantages there are several
disadvantages advantages as well like
yeast artificial chromosome it's very
hard to handle hard to propagate it's
stability is an issue it always get
fragmented and due to many other issues
people
stop using yeast artificial chromosome
as a preferable vector and the switch to
bacterial artificial chromosome in order
to have a higher carrying capacity
vector in order to learn more about
bacterial artificial chromosome
please hit on the link at the end of
this video I hope you enjoyed this video
if you liked this video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe your comments is my motivation
so please comment at the end of this
video
thank you